je m'appelle lehane greyson et je viens
du wisconsin j'espère que vous verrez il
est avec toi je suis une personne
responsable et moral qui s'occupera bien
de votre fils ils ont amené jéricho
lehane greyson la portée disparue depuis
près de cinq jours les si jamais tu me
regardes pitié revient vite
pourquoi te démène temps pour ce bébé
on lui avait donné une famille qui lève
ce n'était pas votre fils et ça ne l'a
jamais si on retrouve les âmes
elle nous mènera à gérer non c'est pas
la gamine tout gentil que tu crois
pourquoi bathyscaphe et caméras il faut
qu'on pense à se protéger en plein
centre a filtré jusque dans nos mers
qu'est-ce qui vous voulez vous il faut
aussi que tu te rendes compte que
bourget dont je serai prête peut faire
n'importe quoi la promesse super tendu
sa présence ici est une infection se
propageant parce que je veux qu'elle est
ce qu'elle mérite
nous allons manquer de temps d'antenne
briller votre vie pour être avec lui
je suis ça marche je ne sais pas
pourquoi je continue je sens qu'elle
côté obscur grandir en moi ça va 30
jours
sani rachat
j'espère que vous verrez que je suis une
personne responsable et moral qui
s'occupera bien dans votre vie
[Musique]